hey what's up on today's show we're
going to be talking about kids we're
going to be talking about
an older mom who's looking back and
wants to reconnect with her children
talking about a mom who's struggling
with her newborn we're going to be
talking about a mom
who is hurt by her 10 year old and what
she can do about it and at the very end
we're going to talk to a husband
who's trying to love his wife better
this is an awesome show
stay tuned
yo yo good folks this is john with the
dr john deloney show
the show for you and about you and by
you
talking about mental health wellness
we're talking about hope
and honesty your marriage your
relational iq
we're talking about people who are still
surprised when they're going into
restaurants and they see somebody with a
temperature
like the little thermometer the little
electronic thing that they beam at your
forehead like we're in star trek
and they still act surprised or
schools or toys r us i don't even know
toys r us is a store anymore but
everyone just acts surprised that people
are taking your temperature can we all
just move on
it's a thing it's super happening here
here's the thing here's the thing
the government told my grandad you're
going to get on a bus
in texas and we're going to drive you to
san diego
and then the government told my granddad
you're going to get off that bus and
you're going to get on a boat
and then the government told my granddad
you're gonna take that boat to the other
side of the world
and fight in a war and then if you come
home that'll be awesome
and then the government told my dad
you're gonna go to the mailbox every
week
and you're gonna see if you got a
lottery number that's gonna send you
halfway across the world to fight
communism
so far the government has asked me to
take an old bandana or a converted bra
or
like something i can buy in walgreens
and put it on my face
and then sit at home and so i think we
can all just take
a couple of xanax dial it back a notch
or two and everyone just go
if that's what they're asking us to do
then i think we're all good right now i
think we're all good
let's all just shake it off let them
point the star trek thing in our heads
and then we can go eat our burgers
everybody just bring it down a notch
or two so if i can help
if i can help call me one eight four
four six nine three
thirty two ninety one that's one eight
four four
six nine three three two nine one
i'm just about common sense man i will
get riled up
we'll get riled up there's a few things
that make me get fired up
and there's a few things that make me go
that's fine
i mean that's what you're asking me to
do i'm cool with that i'm not somebody
who thinks we're gonna be trading
bullets
and coffee for food in the next few
weeks and that may
that may also deserve its own subreddit
thread but
i just don't think that's where we're
headed i trust people and i think at the
end of the day we're doing the best we
can with what we've got so let's all
just cheer up
you can email me at ask john ramsey
solutions.com
we can't cheer up can't you see what's
happening yes i see what's happening
i promise i do but i also promise just
scrolling and being
angry and emailing everybody about it
are thumbs
upping or thumbs downing the crap out of
people come on
come on put the old bandana on go to the
mall
whatever it is put that weird bra thing
that you made on pinterest or whatever i
don't know what it is you're doing for
your masks
just let's move on all right so email me
at ask john
ramseysolutions.com oh my gosh i'm
sending a card and a letter to him right
now
send it that's fine um i'm gonna send a
mean
email i'm gonna tweet at him i don't
even know how twitter works so
rock it on so um email me at ask john
ramsey solutions.com i'm angry good
congratulations high fives so here's the
deal
um i wanna start adding a positive
ending to this show
we're going to keep the song lyrics i
still like that it brings me joy
but i also want to start giving shout
outs to husbands and wives and kids and
grandparents and neighbors
and local people whatever whoever's in
your world
that you know that are making a positive
impact on your mental health on your
relationships that are stepping up in
these gaps and these really wackadoo
hard times i want to give them shout
outs and so email me
positive things that are going on your
life too and we will get you on the show
as well
all right so let's go right to the
phones let's go to renee in detroit
renee what is up how can i help
well good morning dr john and thank you
so much for taking my call
thank you for calling me what's going on
well about seven and a half years ago i
met a great guy in michigan and we
quickly became inseparable and
we started a life together two years
later he moved me to alaska where we
spent the next five years
with his young daughter when i moved to
alaska i left behind my two daughters
who were both in college and a 17 year
old son
in the last 12 months i experienced
three
life altering events that were
devastating and forcing me to move back
to michigan
um and when i when i left michigan
affected and hurt
each of my three kids in different ways
but it was hardest on my youngest son
and since i've had to come home i have
spent time with and talked to all of
them
but i have not been the best role model
and my question to you is what can i do
now to help repair the resentments they
have and rebuild the relationship
that i have with them now
what are the uh things that have
happened though the three devastating
events
well um last summer my mother was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer
i came home commissioned to take care of
her and uh she ended up dying and while
i were protecting her
my partner had an affair with my friend
and married neighbor and i went back to
alaska and
was diagnosed with breast cancer i
ended up leaving there and coming home
back to michigan and
um i i've had i've had a pretty rough
year yeah
so i know you're calling about your kids
can i can we just pause for a second and
say that sucks and i'm sorry that
happened
yep will you say the words
that really sucks
that really sucks i wish there was some
magic
radio things i could say to you through
the airwaves that would make that better
and i can't that's not
fun it's not good and i hate that your
mom went through that pancreatic cancer
that
is evil and loving your mom as she
um dies underneath you as hard and i
hate that for you
and then infidelity sucks especially
after you gave up everything
and you finding out you're sick sucks
and i'm sorry i hate that for you
as for your kids um
you got two dollars in college tell me
about this 17 year old little boy of
yours
was he staying with his real dad when
you went to alaska
he stayed with a friend for a while okay
a family and then he stayed with his
father for a while
so he went through his senior year
without me why didn't he go with you
he didn't want to he didn't want to
leave his friends for him it was not an
option going to alaska
well it is an option because he's a
child he was your kid
why did he get what did he get an option
i'm not sure the answer to that
so how old is he now he's 22 years old
now
is he a 22 year old ball of rage and
anger
i wouldn't say he's a ball of rage and
anger he's he can be climate collected
but he's got he's got some anger issues
yeah it can be hard to talk to him
sometimes yeah imagine he's
it seeds under there how long were you
and
his biological dad divorced before you
left
uh about eight years okay
and so before that how long were things
tough before you actually got divorced
uh about two years we were together 12
about two years
so your son's got about a decade of
chaos and disconnection right and then
mom
took off and um
he's gonna have a lot of healing to do
over the next five to ten to fifteen to
twenty years
how's his how is your biological his
biological father your ex-husband
um he may have been a crummy husband and
we don't have time to get into that but
was he a good dad to your son or no
um he was gone a lot he was gone
all the time okay so when you talk to
your son how do those conversations go
have you ever said i'm sorry um let's
talk and talk about the old days and
have you ever done that how do those
conversations end up i have
talked to him and we kind of both end up
crying it's a real hard conversation and
he it'll be to the point where we both
have to just hang up because we'll be
crying and sad and he doesn't want to
talk about it
sure have you ever written him a letter
nope okay what i think would be
important
is that you write him something that
talks about
not why you did what you did honestly
that doesn't matter it
will some point but not right now what
he needs to know right now is that you
love him
and that you're sorry for leaving him as
a kid he's a child as a 17 year old
and that you're sorry you left him and
that you love him
more than life itself
and that you look forward to being a
part of his life as he grows up
and that you will do whatever you can do
as a grown woman to
be a part of that life and what that's
going to allow him to do
is he'll probably get angry when he
reads it he'll probably cry when he
reads it
but whenever he hangs up that phone he's
got defense mechanisms that are
10 15 years old in his heart and head
that defend him from you because you
left
that defend him from dad because dad
left and
they're able to minimize and shut that
stuff off and it just shoves it down
in a hole in him and what writing
something down for him is going to allow
him to do is to go back to it and go
back
to it and go back to it and allow him to
have a range of emotions reading
your words hearing your voice if you
will without having the defensive
mechanisms to pop up and protect him all
the time
and i'm going to really strongly
recommend you go meet with him in person
if you can
any way make that happen whether that's
inviting him down to your house you
getting in a car or a plane and going to
visit him
this is a conversation a long overdue
conversation probably you'll need to
have in person
more than once of course but it's got to
be one that's not about the past but
it's about i'm sorry i love you now
tell me about your daughters my
daughters are uh they're
they're pretty okay they both have real
good jobs but
they both have um they just
don't they have the attitude they're
here now things are okay we're not going
to worry about the past
it's off the table things are how they
are now and
and i can't do anything to help fix them
they can fix if they want to fix
themselves they can't but i can't help
them fix themselves
uh what's their issues with this well
but
i don't like to use the word fix right
it's i don't like the mechanical
analogies
you can definitely play a healing role
in their life because you're their mom
you will always be there mom you will be
their mom when you're 110 years old
you'll be their mom
and so you can play a healing role have
you ever sat down with him and just said
i'm sorry
and i love you no maybe you're not sorry
about anything i'm just i'm imagining it
i'm assuming that you called no
absolutely i'm consumed with
with guilt and i mean i tell them i love
them all the time but
i think the i'm sorry thing you can only
say it so many times before they go you
know what we got that
it it's that's right and so
how actions speak louder than words like
ah there you go so how close do you live
to them
i'm uh pretty close to the
oldest and the youngest and the other
ones about six hours away so we're all
i mean within traveling distance
okay um if i gave you a really weird
exercise to do would you promise that
you would try it
absolutely all right here's the weird
thing i want you to do number one i want
you to write each one of your kids a
letter
and i want you to tell them not about
the past not hey here's why i did this
and your dad was this
and this other guy was none of that i
want you to tell him that after
you got to the holy awful
terrible but blessed opportunity to be
with your mom
in her last days you recognized how
precious life is and you recognize that
you took off with some new guy to alaska
and left them to fend for themselves
right wrong or different you're allowed
to have done that it's not a
it is what it is but you know that hurt
them
in some various shape form or fashion
and you are carrying around a cinder
block of guilt right now
and i want you to write each one of them
a letter and tell them that you love
them and that you're sorry
and that you look forward to not trying
to repair things because that's
you don't want to live in debt to them
but that
you are thankful to be in their life and
then i want you to do something silly
um not silly something extraordinary
with the ones that are close to you i
want you to tell them
that you're going to come by every week
and you are going to give them a hug for
60 to 90 seconds
you're just gonna hold them and they're
grown-ups and they're gonna roll their
eyes and you're gonna tell them
i'm old and i had breast cancer i'm a
breast cancer survivor i'm gonna hug you
and i want you to hug them as tight as
you possibly can
and i want you to put your bare hand on
the back of their bare neck
so you can feel their skin
and when you're done hugging i want you
to whisper into their ears so they're so
close that your mouth touches their ear
and i want you to say i love you
and that's it
i'm okay okay and if they
if they want to have you know if they
want to eat with you or if they want to
invite you inside great if they don't
great but i want you to tell them um
i've got to do this this is a once a
week assignment that i've got to come in
here and hug you tight
it's probably going to mean more to him
if you tell him you decided to do this
but if you want to tell them
that you talked to somebody on the radio
that recommended you do that you can
tell them that too
all right and then the goal for you is
not to
the difference between guilt and shame
is this you left your 17 year old son
who went to alaska that happened that's
a brick of guilt that you're holding
shame is um guilt is i made a mistake
a big one guilt is i am a mistake i mean
shame is i am a mistake
and you're not okay
do you have access to your son is he one
of the ones that's close to you
yeah how close is he about an hour's
drive
okay so that's gonna be a trek ask if
he'll meet with you once a week or ask
if he'll meet with you once every two
weeks and tell him
i need to hug my son and he may tell you
i don't want you to
um i doubt that he's gonna do that
is that a deal yeah that's a deal he
would not do that i hug him
every time i see him okay i don't want
you just to hug hug him i want you to
hug him as though you're trying to
squeeze his guts out of his body and i
want you to hang on to him
and then i want your lips to touch his
ear when you tell him you love him okay
okay
and then after uh maybe a month of this
i want you to call me back or shoot me
an email and let me know how it's going
and i'll read the email and if you write
back and say this was so
stupid my kids hate me and they think
this was the dumbest thing ever
i'll read that on on the on the podcast
and i'll let america know that i'm dumb
but i almost guarantee you they won't
and then i want you to ask him about the
holiday season
i want you to ask him about um can you
come over
and help them rake their front yard i
want you to ask them about hey
can we and we'll build these things
moving forward together
around meals and fun times and laughter
and joy but right now
they need to know that their mom's here
and like you said it perfectly this is
about action now it's not about more
words and more words
but that letter is going to be important
a letter not about the past but about
the present and the future
and i want to tell you you have had a
crappy ear renee and
the only way to heal through some of
these seasons to grieve through these
seasons
is with other people and so i'm so proud
of you i'm so grateful for you for
wanting to heal these relationships
it's going to be hard it's going to be
humbling but your kids are going to be
excited to have their mama back
what a gift what a gift all right let's
go to
it's leela is that did i say that right
yeah all right leela in logan utah i did
it
yes all right so what's going on how's
it going in your world
um you know there's a lot up in the air
but we're excited about the future and
i'm really excited to talk to you
about awesome i'm excited to talk to you
so what's going on
okay so i have two kids i have a two and
a half year old
and i have a six month old oh you are in
it right
yeah just wait so much in it so
oh girl four months ago my two and a
half year old
who had been weaned for a full year
decided that she needed to breastfeed
again like her little brother
oh she's back all right yeah so we've
been doing that for four months at first
i thought she was curious so i was like
we'll go with it she'll get over this
really fast
she weaned so easily she was all into
like real food
this isn't gonna be a thing so now it's
like she's asking for milk more than he
does
and i am dehydrated and just like kind
of emotionally exhausted
yes like i cuddle with her and i want to
spend time with her
but i also i don't want it to always be
involving milk and i don't know how to
like transition
and keep him being breastfeed yes so
tandem breastfeeding right i i've heard
about this i've read about this you're
the first person i'm actually
experienced talking through this with
and so you're two and a half year old i
guess at the time she was a little over
two
she came back and was it something you
were excited to do did you feel guilty
about it was it just a weird
tell me about that i had never
so okay i don't think breastfeeding
itself is weird at all
so i've been like good with that i love
the cuddles with my kids
so that wasn't an issue but then she was
just so curious and i try not to say
no to her unless i have a really good
reason to say no i let her be curious
about stuff
right so i was like okay we'll see where
this goes and i just thought
this was gonna be like a one-time thing
and then she's gonna be over it no way
dude yeah no way man
she gets that direct line connection she
gets to be between you
and this other new lunatic that you
brought into the home right
she gets to weasel right between those
two weasels not a nice way to say that
but
um so let's take the the two kids off
for a second
you mentioned the physical part of this
but you also
you said it i don't like to say no um so
you're in the middle
of emotional spiritual psychological
world and i don't mean spiritual like in
the
the whatever the jesus he churchy sense
i mean
spiritual like this is existential for
you
so there is a part of you tell me if i'm
wrong that
when you are nursing both of your kids
at once that's magical
and then there's a part of you that this
is literally
wearing you out from the inside out is
that fair
both of those are 100 true okay so what
do you want to do
um or both probably right
yeah so i think like the deepest part of
me just wants my daughter to know how
much i love
her right and since this is the way she
wants to hear it
i don't know how to change to something
else
because if i say no she just she just is
a wreck
and she just cries and she's so sad and
she doesn't get like that about
everything else and she comes
she wants milk when she's gone through
something that's scary
or hurts her or she's just having a hard
day
and i just like i want to protect her
and she's not
cuddly so if i try to cuddle her she
like wiggles out and she leaves
so so i'm getting something out of this
relationship that is important for me
too
but i'm waking up every morning feeling
like
like i'm getting headaches and i have
chronic pain that's worsened by
being dehydrated and i feel like no
matter how much water i drink that's not
enough
right so and so i kind of need to find
another option
i want to preface this with the last
thing on planet earth
the world needs is a
40 year old male talking to a woman
about telling her what she needs to be
doing with breastfeeding right
the last thing the world needs is
another dude sticking his head into some
of these conversations all right
so i want to go ahead and tell everyone
there is
few things on earth with more opinions
than breastfeeding right
there are all kinds of tribes around all
different kinds of things i get that
um if you are into tandem breastfeeding
for you and for your kids
and i know what the world health
organization says about two years i know
all that stuff
okay so i'm talking to just
lovely leela in utah and so don't send
me mean cards and letters everyone
in the podcast world so
um if that's something you want to
continue that's something you want to
continue that's between you
and your kids i think you
know ex know exactly where the challenge
is here and it is
not with your two-year-old it's with you
and it's that initial panic meltdown
your daughter's
is it daughter or is that right yeah
okay
your daughter is feeling like she no
longer owns you and this is a great way
to control you
and she is just leaning up against these
boundaries and one of the greatest
things you could teach her
is that mommy has body boundaries
and that everyone from dad to her to new
baby
respects mommy's body boundaries and
anytime somebody puts up new
boundaries particularly for young kids
um but
even when wives put them up for their
husbands and husbands put them up for
their why
boundaries are hard for us especially at
first and
your two-year-old daughter
two-and-a-half-year-old is going to
crash up against those boundaries and
try to kick them over
because she just wants to see if they're
going to hold and if they're firm at the
end of the day the bigger challenge is
not with her but it's with you
and so i want you to feel 1 000 affirmed
that you are more than welcome to the
autonomy of your body
and you are more than welcome you're not
going to ruin your kid in fact you're
going to empower your kid
because right now she's not having to do
the work to learn the psychological
and emotional and spiritual responses to
discontent to fear to frustration she's
just literally
able to run to mom right right to mom's
bosom literally
and so what what's going to be
critical for you in this is exhausting
season and i get that
man you have a two and a half year old
and six month old there's no way around
it um
is finding intentional time not cuddle
time
but eye contact time reading time
special mommy and daughter time with
your two and a half year old
another thing that can be key is giving
your two and a half year old jobs
participation leadership roles
especially a young
young daughter who's becoming a young
woman you're training you're raising a
young woman
and so here are some roles some
leadership opportunities she can take
but the reality is it's just going to be
hard for a little while
a great professor of mine her name was
aretha marbley she's one of the most
important mentors i've ever had
she said one of the keys to helping that
first kid when you have a second kid
is to start referred to referring to it
not as the baby
but as your sister
as your brother and two-year-olds
three-year-olds four-year-olds they
crave ownership so much that your
daughter craves ownership of
you right now and so what you're going
to be able to do is transition that
ownership from your body
to your your sister needs your help
right now
your sister needs you to fill in the
blank here's some jobs
here are some things i need she needs
you to color a picture and read her the
story or whatever the things are
um it's gonna give her some autonomy but
it's just going to be a hard
frustrating tearful for you and for her
separation over the next few weeks
is dad a good participant here is he a
good helper
that's a great helper dad is probably on
the same page you're on he's like
she's going to cry it's going to be hard
like we just have to make her do it
and i just breaks my heart it does
but that's also been really busy lately
he's finishing school he's working
full-time
we're about to move so jolly so
so the real thing that you've got to do
leela the real thing you've got to do is
recognize the truth that you are also
using this
as a stress coping mechanism too
and if you can come up in this messy
crazy season and i realize i'm on such
thin ice
being just a dude telling a nursing mom
you know what you need to do
i get that right but um your husband's
busy
you got a six-month-old who's not
sleeping through the night you've got a
two and a half year old you're about to
move transition transition transition
it does make everybody just exhale a
little bit when you've got both kids
that are quiet
both of your babies your gut you've got
huddled up on your you know
i can't even imagine the connection you
can have with the child there
i hugged my daughter this morning we
just she just woke up a little bit early
and we just got some great snuggle time
this morning
i can't imagine how much deeper that
could be right than what you get to
experience
but you've got to start developing and
owning and getting some
friends in your life that can push you
and hold you accountable to getting some
stress coping skills that don't
involve your two and a half year old
that don't involve your six month old
you've got to start coming up with some
things for you in whatever limited
squishy time you've got that will bring
you peace
and it will bring you some restoration
is that fair i know that's so hard yeah
it's just a totally different way than
how i've been thinking about it but it's
very valid and that helps to see it that
way
or maybe oh gosh i'm just thinking about
the
the the breastfeeding cards and letters
i'm gonna get
um maybe don't send me letters maybe
thinking about
me thinking about your daughter as she's
not a xanax
and so every time she comes to you and
you're just
thinking she's not my pacifier she's not
my xanax
and this is gonna be hard for a few
weeks but and making sure you know what
your steps are gonna be
i'm gonna this is i'm gonna go take a
walk this is where i'm gonna get some
sleep this is i'm gonna go talk to
somebody because i'm struggling
whatever those things are um but i i
think your heart is so
there and your husband's right you got
an awesome partner you're i'm smiling
right now because i know this is going
to be hard but it's going to be so worth
it
and i'll tell you this if you can teach
your daughter
how to appropriately respond if you can
model for her body boundaries if you can
model for her
when mommy gets tired and stressed
here's the healthy things i do
you are setting her up for a
extraordinary
legacy shifting life and if you teach
her
that when things get bad mommy will just
hold you and i'll always take care of
the discomfort and whenever you get
scared and fearful mommy will solve
those problems for you
um that's a hard road to hoe now she's
two right of course mom's gonna be there
right um and i'm not telling you well it
sucks kid go outside and go for a jog
right
no she's two and a half right um but
beginning to hold those boundaries hold
that autonomy you get your wellness
behavior you put your oxygen mask on
first
and give her some ownership and autonomy
and now she is
a she's a big sister and she's going to
learn some new skills and new boundaries
here it's going to be extraordinary so
thank you so much for that call leela um
you are awesome your husband's awesome
your kids
it's going to be a blast um and i will
be thinking about you during the next
few weeks as you all transition
to where you're just breastfeeding one
kid which already sounds
like a cartwheel box of monkeys and
adventures so
all right let's go to ashley in dallas
texas
ashley good morning how are we doing
good morning dr jaloni uh we are
nervous as i'll get out hey i'm nervous
too i'm nervous too
so how can i help you this morning um i
am i've reached out because i am needing
some guidance
on how to not
let my 10 year old unknowingly hurt my
feelings
uh what'd she do or he do uh
so uh she actually um
she said that so she as though she's
like some mistress
this is gonna be awesome so she um we
were in the car and she was
really excited about this a-plus that
she got on
a homework assignment and i you know
asked her what
you know what it was about and the
prompt was
describe in detail a memory of something
you have done
that you believe will be a lifelong
memory um
so see started i asked her i said wow
that sounds great what do you you know
what were
what were your ideas and she went
through her brainstorming process with
me
in the car and as she was going through
each
memory um i realized that every single
one
uh was one that she had with her dad
um who's my ex-husband
and uh it just she
you know she wasn't intentionally doing
it she was just really excited about the
grade that she got
and um i was
hurt i was thinking of all of the things
that we've done
all of the experiences that i have tried
to provide
my husband and myself try to provide her
and how none of that
is anything that came to mind and
i yeah i just need a little
insight yeah does she live with you full
time
she split custody how does she live so
she um lives with me and
her stepfather and uh we actually we
live in texas
um her we actually just moved here a
year ago so her
dad her biological father lives in
a different state and um the
agreement that we came up with was that
she would be with us during the school
year
and uh we tried to make it as 50 50 as
possible which is impossible when you
have a kid that's in school
so she spends every single school
holiday
with her dad okay and
so when she was rattling off these great
life memories
she's so excited she got an a plus what
were some of the memories give me two or
three of them that she rattled off there
um one was a wedding that she went to
and um a cruise
and finding our first sharks tooth
um so those are the
three big ones that i can pull right now
so
what i'm gonna tell you isn't gonna
bring you joy
or it's not going to make you happy i
hope that it will lodge into your heart
okay how long has she lived with you
specifically for a year
how long have you all been divorced uh
we've been divorced since
2017
okay so several years okay
so i want you to think of yourself as
the anchor
as done already done the the poll that
is
17 feet in concrete down on the ground
and i want you to think of her
biological dad as
this probably isn't fair so i'm just um
i'm
making generalizations here but he is
the cotton candy in the fireworks
yeah yep and for a 10 year old cotton
candy rules
right fireworks are so shiny and fun
and they don't think about because
they're 10
the oatmeal and the bedtimes and the
clothes cleaning
and the ironing and the school and the
anda and the
and just having to deal with school
holidays
is just the hot dogs and mustard
and fireworks and cotton candy and gummy
candies it's not the day-to-day grind
and so that particular moment i can only
imagine
hurt but i want to give you a
perspective on a 10 year old brain that
is just searching for
the fireworks right you are her anchor
you are lodged in
and the tethers between the two of you
is so
deep and so strong that she has the
opportunity to swing off the edge of a
mountain
and go with her dad
and she can only have those experiences
because she is completely lodged in with
you
and so if you can hear those fun
experiences not as a slight to you
but but as only because of you
my hope is is that smile that you have
would say
you're dang right
and i don't want you to get sucked on a
rabbit hole that 10 year olds live in
which is life is about
fireworks and cotton candy well why
can't life be about fireworks and cotton
candy though
it would be awesome but we also have
diabetes and forest fires
it doesn't work like that i wish it
could too
but when she has her first
heartbreak she's going to call you and
when she first
that first knucklehead in class reaches
over and holds her hand she's going to
tell you
and the first time she gets a d on an
assignment and she's crying so hard she
can't breathe she's going to tell you
and so when you think of what's your
greatest memory i don't even like those
assignments for kids and i know they're
writing prompts and they're fine but
they start to direct 10 year olds to
look for flashy things
as opposed to what makes you feel safe
and right and again i don't want to
criticize teachers they're kicking butt
and they are just
living the hero's life right now they're
running the world keeping us afloat
right now but
those are hard prompts but what i want
to challenge you with as the adult
is to hear those fireworks statements to
hear those gummy bear statements as
that's because of me
and i feel like that that feels selfish
do what that feels selfish your mom
you're allowed to be selfish
okay you're allowed to be
okay and it may be a fun
exercise for you just to sit with her
and um do y'all do b w's every night
thumbs up thumbs downs best and worsts
of the day
um yeah we yeah we we discuss our
victories as is this
there you go so take ownership in those
um this is a trite thing that i say all
the time but it's the truth
ten-year-olds don't get a vote they just
don't because they're 10.
if 10 year olds around the world we'd
all eat nachos and
marshmallows every day of the week for
every meal of the week and that would be
awesome until all of our teeth fell out
of our head and we all went insane
and so 10 year olds don't get a vote you
know
you know his mom that you're doing
hero's work
that you're trying to make sure that
she's got a great relationship with her
father and he's probably doing a great
job too
he's probably leaning in the best he can
he's all live in a different state now
it's going to be messy it's going to be
hard
you're going to live with some mom guilt
because of the divorce because of the
separation because of the kids going
back and forth that's just going to be
part of it
i want you to give yourself some grace
but more importantly when your kid is
able to
go see the fireworks it's because you
brought her there
when she was able to enjoy that cotton
candy it's because you make sure she's
fed and healthy
every day of the week every meal of the
week
and so when my 10 year old leans back
and says that other dad does this
i say yup that's awesome because i know
he's anchored in with me and your baby
girl's ankle
anchored in with you so thank you so
much for that call ashley
let's take one more call let's go to ron
in cincinnati
what's up ron how we doing brother
you're doing great
john uh really really appreciative for
what you do for us
well i'm appreciative of you for giving
me a shout man how can i help this
morning
yeah so um been married for five years
the love of my life um best five years
ever
raising two kids together um one
kink in our marriage that yeah that i
want to get rid of
my wife has some pretty fragile mental
health
and she gets triggered often and i think
in a very logical solution-based way
and does it really work for her when she
is in those triggered states
and actually heightens her her emotions
um when i'm trying to provide her
solutions yeah oh
ron are you are you a solution giver
i am great so i i'm trying to get some
advice on you know what i can do to step
outside of that solution-based mindset
and just empathize with her
when she's going through some of the
things that i may not think of
as big of a deal as she thinks they are
um
but you know i just want to you know
kind of slow myself down
and step outside of that uh giving her
solutions and just
really be in the moment and empathize
with her so when you tell her she's
number one
thanks for being a guy who's willing to
look in the mirror and say
maybe i'm contributing to this and so
high five brother i appreciate you
um so uh when you say she's got a lot of
mental health or a fragile mental health
what does that mean
real quick what does that mean um she
she grew up with an alcoholic parent
okay so
yeah so um her whole life was
a was a gap right was it was her parent
abusive
or just absent or just an addict a
little a little bit abusive um
she spent a lot of our childhood seeking
validation
um right you know from yeah so um
it really triggers her when she's
seeking validation and then doesn't get
it now in her adult stage
yeah um especially from her parents
right right so that's a whole other
phone call right how to deal with those
folks
um so paint me a picture of a scenario
right she is struggling she is spinning
out
um she has somebody at work says
something to her
that you would normally just laugh off
and she comes home
and she is curled up on the couch in a
ball and you're like whoa what happened
and she tells you and your first thought
is that's not even a big deal
what do you do right what do you do next
just uh my uh this is kind of
embarrassing to say out loud hey listen
we are in it together man i promise you
whatever you're about to say i've
probably done too
yeah i i really just tell her like you
know don't
don't let it affect you that much like
you're stronger than
what you're displaying right now um you
know those people don't have an
influence on your life just
really don't let that don't let it get
to you that that much
right kind of the route i take and so
the word you
you so listen number one i know that you
care about her
and that's why you're trying to help her
in that way and so the fact that you're
not a dismissive
partner right you're not just like
whatever dude and you don't just leave
good for you okay i know that you're
reaching out and you're trying to love
her the best you know how
and you got two knucklehead little kids
running around there too right when all
this is going on right
right so you said it perfectly so i'm
just going to help you connect the dots
that are already in your own heart and
mind
earlier you said as a child which is
common of
of kids of whose parents are addicts
she was chasing validation and she
wanted to be
valid to them she wanted them to connect
with her she wanted them to notice her
and value her
and addicts don't they value their
addictions they value their unplugging
right
their disconnection and so when she says
hey this happened
what she really wants is for her husband
to validate her your feelings are real
and when you try to solve those feelings
with info with information
her are you in my valid alarms start
ringing off the hook
because you are saying those aren't
valid what you should be doing is fill
in the blank
and so think of it in terms of
validation now here's the deal we all
have feelings and our feelings
are important and they lie to us right
they're not always truthful
the way we work through whether they're
truthful or not
is being safe are we in circumstances
where we're safe or we're okay
and so the greatest gift you could give
to your wife
is the idea of validation
your presence and so the next time she's
struggling in fact i would pre-struggle
before she starts struggling i would
start setting it up and you can tell her
hey i talked to delony and
here's a thing he wants us to try and
it's literally brother like 30 days
a month or two months of every single
day i want you to sit down before she
leaves for work before you go to work
and i want you to hold her hands and
look at her in the eye just for a weird
awkward 10 seconds
and say i love you how's today going so
far and it may be
six o'clock in the morning and she could
say dude i just got up it's going
fine and you can say thank you for
sharing that
because what you're doing is you're
practicing
being present but not giving advice and
it's something you're going to have to
practice i know you want to fix her
mental health which you can't do
but you can change the way you respond
to things
and i want you to not think of your wife
as a car that you can fix
or i don't want you to think of a
problem at work that you have to solve
i want you just to think of somebody
that you love and then when you get home
from work and you see that she's had a
rough day or a great day
i want you to do that again i want you
to grab her hands and look her in the
eye for an awkward 10 seconds
and then i want you to say how was today
and if she says
this happened and it sucks and it was
awful and it was the worst thing ever
and i can't breathe and i just want to
have four glasses of wine
i want you to tell her um well forget
the wine part
not four glasses of wine i can help but
i want you to tell her
um thank you so much for sharing that
with me
i appreciate you being vulnerable and i
love you and then i want you to hug her
for about 30 seconds or 60 seconds
without stopping
and then let that be that and you are
gonna feel like there's so much left
unsaid and i didn't help her i didn't
fix her
my guess is she's pretty smart is she
pretty smart
a genius yeah there you go so think of
this
she doesn't need your information dude
she knows she's smart
what she needs is you to validate her
and not through words
she needs you to validate her through
connection and touch and through
presence
and the beautiful thing here is man i'm
literally smiling if you watch this on
youtube i'm smiling
because i know you're a good guy and i
know you're gonna you want to
not just give her the right answers i
know you want to love your wife the best
you can
yeah and that's yeah man that is every
every guy who works in my space wants to
just meet guys who want to
love their partners with all their
hearts and your
beautiful wife has that and so the
practice for you
is not trying to solve her problems
here's another tip
if she continues to ask to talk about
the same thing the same thing the same
thing
ask her are you inviting me into this
conversation do you want my advice
or do you want me to be present got you
you sound like you're are you are you
hearing this or is it is it making sense
or not making sense
it's it's all it's all click it's it's
all stuff that i've had
pieces uh pieces to but just couldn't
put the whole puzzle together
um you know my wife and i have had
multiple conversations about this is why
i'm finally reaching out
um i'm just like i was just kind of lost
but
you know the definitely the looking into
her eyes and
asking her you know hey how was your day
we don't do that ever you know we often
we often do not do that it's more so
coming
to me when something actually arises um
that has triggered her so
she was she worked a separate schedule
than i do you know i
am a hvac technician i work during the
day she's a waitress so she works during
the night
um so we often don't have that connect
time yeah
to be able to do that so you know making
time for that
is a big deal um you know that was
that was a huge piece of the puzzle that
was missing for me and
on the way home from your hvac job if
you have to pull over on the side of the
road
and grab some wildflowers
if you have to run into a store and grab
her favorite something or other if on
the back
of some old air conditioning ducts
tape that you got off of an old house i
want you to write her a note
every day that jess says
who you are is beautiful and i love you
and i want you to constantly constantly
show up for her not with information but
with you
because you're awesome and what's going
to happen over time is she's going to
begin to
her shoulders will drop she won't search
for validation from you because she will
feel it
at her in her soul right in her
mitochondria she will feel you
and then she will feel safe and you know
who else is going to start feeling safe
your kids
and they're not going to live
ping-ponging off the walls as much
they're still kids they're still going
to do that
but they're going to begin to feel safe
in the house
and they're going to begin to feel safe
in relationship with you guys
and what you're talking about now my man
is you're talking about generational
legacy change
you're talking about raising kids that
are never going to know the
disconnection and lack of validation
that your wife experienced
that you experience when she's hurting
you just want to reach across that
island you don't know how to do it
but if you cannot look at her as an hvac
unit but look at her as your soul mate
my man ron you're talking about new
family trees being planted in forests
and dude you're not going to get to eat
the fruit of these trees
but your great grandkids will and man
i'm i'm glad that you're my last call of
the day um
you are leaving me with a smile on my
face because i know you're going to be a
guy who makes these major transitions
you're going to teach yourself new
skills you're going to learn new skills
and you're going to
golly man wrap your hands around your
wife's heart it's going to be awesome
i do want you to call me back in about a
month i want you to know how let me know
how things are going shoot me an email
i'll read it here on the air
i'm excited for you and your wife and
where y'all are headed that's awesome
so as we wrap up um here's the deal
i'm just gonna cut to it greatest song
of all time
from the number one greatest movie of
all time
not debatable i love titanic nope
um oh my gosh the greatest notebook nope
greatest movie of all time is stand by
me
stand by me is the greatest movie ever
made
and it was based on a stephen king
novella
and it was named after the greatest song
ever written
by ben e king in 1961
it was so good it didn't even get an
album they just put it out as a single
because they're just like we don't even
need an album this song is so incredible
here you go world and it's been covered
i don't know
8 trillion times benny king's
masterpiece
it goes like this when the night has
come and the land is dark and the moon
is the only light we'll see i won't be
afraid
no i won't be afraid just as long as you
stand
by me if the sky that we look upon
should tumble and fall
or the mountain should crumble to the
sea i won't cry
i won't cry no i won't shed a tear just
as long as you stand
by me so darling stand by me
everybody's we're heading off into the
election season as we're heading off
into whatever the end of 2020 is going
to look like let's stand by one another
this is the dr john dolone's show
[Music]
you